now that Davos attendees and that quaint
little town in Switzerland you know they
have to be very reassured on the
realization that nothing that they
Advocate or no Panic that they induce
will ever harm their bottom line
so we need to work together to close the
emissions Gap and that means to phase
out progressively coal and supercharge
the renewable Revolution
to end the addiction to forcing fuels
emissions are still going up all these
promises of the last few years to cut a
mission emissions are still going up
when are we going to bring these
emissions down we cannot let the oil
companies and gas companies and Petro
States tell us what is permissible
he's like a human version of the
Hindenburg he's going to explode at any
moment all right these pronouncements
from people like Gore and the rest of
the uh big big wigs at Davos they
oftentimes lead to real policy
pronouncements and we don't have to look
any further than in California that's
the incubator for left-wing ideas and
it's been the leading state in the move
to transition away from fossil fuels the
addiction as he said to fossil fossil
fuels but what are the repercussions of
this the costs according to a new report
one third of oil and gas workers forced
out of jobs due to the greenac policies
will not be able to even find other jobs
at all and for those that do nearly 30
percent will earn less joining me now is
Mike Rowe host of how America works on
Fox Business Prime and Dirty Jobs on the
Discovery Channel
Mike now as the expert on jobs that make
everybody's lives easier uh your
reaction to this callous and dismissive
attitude of the Elites at Davos of jobs
that they don't approve of
it's hard
to maintain a consistent level of
outrage I've been at this for 15 years
the foundation I run is is focused on
real jobs that require an actual skill
that that truly exists and honestly
Laura when I when I look at some of the
coverage of Davos you know I don't I
guess I don't understand why anybody is
taking any of it seriously honestly I I
watch it year after year these are
billionaires and very very very wealthy
people who fly privately to this resort
to basically blame the everyday guy
for all of the trouble in the world so I
I think maybe my answer is I just don't
know how a reasonable person can see
through the hypocrisy to even for a
moment seriously consider the validity
of anything you just played well the
fact of the matter is you know Joe Biden
and his environmental team are moving a
pace obviously the Keystone Pipeline
canceled we see oil and gas permitting
at record stall outs now you know people
refusing to invest in oil and gas
because of this ESG and green movement
Mike so while I agree with you these
guys are just total blowhards and and
many of them total frauds on this issue
the policies come out of the corporate
push in many cases and it's not the
other way around the corporations are
pushing for this quote Revolution
because I think they're going to make a
lot of money either way no matter what
happens they always come out on top
yeah I agree it's kind of an Unholy
Alliance and most bad ideas take on a
certain kind of inertia right that gets
pushed and pulled from a lot of
different places and sometimes I'm
afraid things just have to go Splat
before the regular majority will just
stand up and go whoa whoa look it's fine
to talk about Renewables it's well and
good and I I think in our best interest
to look at other ways to fuel the planet
but to affirmatively make fossil fuels
the enemy right now and to marginalize
and to vilify
the very thing that we are all so
completely and totally Reliant upon
that's a recipe for crazy making and
you're right you can see it everywhere
certainly our relationship with energy
is profoundly disconnected our
relationship with food also disconnected
where it we're at war with the very
things that we need and so look I work
on the shows I work on because it gives
me a chance to point to people who I
believe are connected to the things that
matter most energy and food what's going
on in Switzerland right now I
I don't get it yeah but in California by
the way where the state is destroying
another critical industry which is
independent Trucking Mike this recent
piece of National Review explains that a
law that Newsom Governor Newsom signed
in 2019
forces Independent Drivers to surrender
the companies that they've built and
seek employment in large firms that can
go on to hire them what the heck kind of
impact does this have on costs Americans
and yeah this is something that in my
view is is maybe the biggest unreported
story in the country right now ab5 is
the assembly Bill you're referring to
it's become law you're right Newsome
signed it uh will Swaim uh wrote the
article in the National Review and I had
him on my podcast to talk about it
because it's not just truckers right
this started with uh ride sharing Lyft
sort of Silicon Valley thing it's moved
into all aspects of freelance work and
the gig economy and it is completely
under Fire there's a trucker named Tom
Odom who you should talk to you would
really enjoy this guy he came from
nothing out of East L.A he built a
business he Nets close to two hundred
thousand dollars a year driving his own
truck
it's over for him he's gone he's moving
to Texas and seventy thousand other
independent truckers in this state are
looking at the end of the way they want
to work and if you think that it's going
to impact
everything in the supply chain anybody
with anything in their house that was
ever on a truck is going to be impacted
by this and look maybe it's too late for
California but there's an act in
Congress right now to take this thing
Nationwide and people need to pay
attention to that for sure they like
like big they don't like small business
which is why so many entrepreneurs are
becoming politically more conservative
it's obvious what's that they love the
big conglomerates then that means more
power and more you're right connection
with the government Mike thank you for
what you do you highlight the everyday
heroes in our society and we really
appreciate you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else